[Música]
y en directo a vamos hasta santiago de
chile- para conversar con nuestra
corresponsal patricia luna sobre el
cierre de campañas a favor y en contra
de la nueva constitución porque este
domingo los electores chilenos deberán
aprobarla o rechazarla en un plebiscito
a tres días de la votación la tendencia
todavía no es clara patricia buenas
noches cuéntenos cómo se desarrolló este
cierre de campañas
buenas noches a tres horas de que se
produzca el cierre total de las campañas
y se inicie la veda electoral de dos
días que impide hablar de una u otra
opción la campaña de la prueba y del
rechazo todavía sigue en este momento
celebrándose en las calles de santiago
con un diferente balance tenemos las
imágenes del drone que muestran un
evento absolutamente masivo que coloca
las grandes avenidas del centro de
santiago por el apruebo donde se
desarrolla en el escenario un acto
cultural que cuenta con artistas como
inti illimani y quilapayún ana tijoux
grandes artistas vinculados a las ideas
progresistas mientras que el rechazo
eligió como escenario el alto de una
colina una colina muy importante de
santiago el cerro san cristóbal en un
acto que no ha sido tan masivo en el que
predomina en la bandera chilena que fue
desplegada con gran tamaño una grande
con una gran bandera de gran tamaño que
se veía desde lejos y donde el acto tuvo
un carácter mucho más de ciudadanos sin
voceros conocidos sin ex constituyentes
sin figuras políticas pero una menor
afluencia de público patricia y es que
la jornada y el ambiente también
estuvieron cargados de tensiones
así es que venimos con unas jornadas
bastante tensas en chile hay mucha
presencia en el ambiente hay mucha
incertidumbre y ha habido una gran
sorpresa hoy al ver la gran cantidad de
personas que se han
concentrado veíamos por la calle caminar
a muchas personas con banderas en su
mano para acudir al acto del apruebo
esto ha sido una sorpresa que contradice
un poco lo que dicen hasta el momento
las encuestas que dan como favorita la
opción en el rechazo en la mayoría de
los casos el ambiente está muy tenso
esta mañana había también
manifestaciones a favor de los presos de
la revuelta que culminaban en algunos
casos y también se producían incidentes
violentos por ejemplo en el alameda que
acaban con el hermano del presidente de
boliche siendo lesionado siendo atacado
por un grupo de personas también le
robaron el celular se vio en unos días
de mucha tensión y mucha efervescencia
también gran incertidumbre en chile ante
esta que va a ser una de las elecciones
más históricas que ha vivido el país en
los últimos años con la gran incógnita
también de que el voto obligatorio
a una masa de electores cuyo
comportamiento no pueden predecir las
encuestas veremos qué es lo que pasa
todas las opciones están a dietas